Hello, everybody. This is Dr. Kevin Cutters. And on today's Dr. Cutters live, I want to talk about growth pathways and cancer, specifically the mTOR or the Keras pathways.
I talked about this a lot before, but I just feel like hitting here again in some of the interventions that we could deal with are very important.
Your mTOR pathway right here is a major genetic metabolic pathway in your body and how you heal and how you deal with cell replication and deal with cell growth.
Remember when we talk about cancer, cancer is a uncontrolled cell replication, but we don't want to confuse that cell replication and cell growth.
Henceforth, healing is a bad thing. Of course, if we cut ourselves, we need to heal. Our body is constantly breaking down and growing new cells.
That's part of regeneration. That's part of staying healthy. It is when a cell goes through rapid replication because something's damaged to the DNA, which we've spoken about in bacteria.
The fungus chemical toxin gets in there, damages the DNA, damages different pathways, which are supposed to cause cell death, can damage pathways that proliferate cell growth accelerate cell growth.
And that's what we're talking about. That's what can cause cancer, it can lead to cancer. So anything that's going to stimulate the mTOR pathway and the Keras pathways, we want to look at what we're dealing with the cancer patient.
So all these things up top up here, EMF cell tower, high fructose corn syrup, too much iron in your diet, tanky methyl groups as a supplement. We see that a lot with cancer patients coming into their already unhigh methyl supplements.
And with that is that can stimulate, it does stimulate mTOR and stimulates growth. So think of mTOR as a major growth pathway. We don't want to over stimulate mTOR if we have cancer.
So is there anything wrong with taking Sammy and methyl B12 and methyl folate if you don't have cancer? Well, there can be, but technically there won't be as far as growth goes. But certainly with somebody with cancer, we don't want to stimulate that pathway.
MSG glutamate excess glutamine in bone broth, too much animal proteins. We'll stimulate that pathway and stimulate mTOR, pesticide exposure.
Especially the person who has pond lung defects is going to end up increasing mTOR. And again, MTHFR supplementation. Also, we look on this side, dairy protein drinks, plastics exposure, all are going to stimulate different pathways that are going to stimulate growth.
So we have to be careful of those things. That's, this is a real nice chart. You can sit here. We could talk about it for hours, but we want to move on. But these are the things that we want to look at.
How can we shut down or slow down mTOR? Well, what would just brief look at this chart that just eliminating or close to eliminating as many of these things on this list here can help slow down mTOR.
I'll dare you to try to eliminate my EMS and stay away from sugar, stay away from iron supplements and methyl supplements and animal proteins and glutamine supplements and pesticides and such is going to slow down these growth pathways.
Everything in red here has to do with the genes that we look at. Because the person with pond lung defects is going to end up with problems.
And they're going to end up with problems that get into D.A.O. defects. So that's all our genetic workup that we do with cancer patients.
This is Keras mutations, meaning Keras is a gene, Keras is another growth pathway. People with Keras mutations defects on that gene pathway. And that's why we look at them when we look at somebody's genetics.
We want to help increase that growth pathway that we want to address. So there's different drugs that are in the market right now to help block this.
But we look at some different supplementations that you could do to help block this too.
What are the major supplementations that can help block this is curcumin.
So curcumin is the product of turmeric, the active ingredient in turmeric. So using curcumin can help decrease that Keras pathway.
Here's another slide that took for the article. It was actually a lung cancer. That's why I talked about DNA damaging due to cigarette smoke components.
We could say DNA damage to any toxins within a cell that could cause cancer or the biotoxins in a cell that cause cancer can stimulate certain pathways that cause survival proliferation.
Think of that. Why would that be? You got a toxin inside the cell. Well, our body is trying to survive. That cell is trying to survive.
They can stimulate different pathways that promote cell proliferation, but also stimulates the Keras pathway, which can cause survival proliferation to blocks a poptosis, a poptosis is your normal program cell death.
And it's again in your body's infinite wisdom is trying to keep the cell alive, but when there's something that's damaged the DNA and the cell and you got rapid replication within the Keras pathway is not our friend.
So if it's not a cancer that's in the person's body, one of the Keras is our friend, but when a cell is in rapid replication, we do that to have cancer in our body.
Keras is not our friend. Keras also stimulates NF Campo Beta. We've talked a lot about that in the past. That's a inflammatory program that shuts down a poptosis and all the genes that will help stimulate a poptosis again in order to keep the cell alive.
It also even shuts down your P53. So Keras can shut down your P53. Remember, your P53 is your is your tumor suppressor pathway, your multiple tumor suppressor pathways, but P53 is your major tumor suppressor pathway inside the cell.
That means when the cell goes into rapid replication, P53 is kicked in and when P53 is kicked in, it is supposed to produce a stimulation of cell death, your capsaic pathway.
And that will help stimulate a poptosis and kill the cell that is a cancer cell. And that's why most of us don't end up with a diagnosis of cancer because our tumor suppressor genes are doing their job.
So when something is damaged inside the cell and the cell starts to go through rapid replication, your tumor suppressor pathways kick in and cause a poptosis cause cell death.
Well, if there are toxins inside the cell, they can damage the the Keras pathway, or if there are defects on the Keras pathway, it can stimulate more Keras production, increase nuclear factor capa B and can help in this way, hinder the production or stimulation of P53 and end up promoting cell survival, which is what we don't want to do.
So we want P53 to kick in. So again, Keras is not our friend in this scenario. There's another great response, another great slide on the P53 pathway again, the P53 pathway is your major tumor suppressor pathway.
So when the P53 pathway kicks in, you have growth arrest, meaning that growth will stop.
Apoptosis will take place. Apoptosis is is it protects the cell from continued growth and what apoptosis is is normal program cell death. So it causes the cell to go through normal program cell death.
P53 also helps with DNA repair, which is quite interesting, but the Keras pathway is again can block this. This is what this isn't going to mess that up, but this read the Keras pathway will block P53.
So when there's over stimulation of that Keras pathway, in this case, talking about a mutation or a defect of the Keras genes, it causes hyper proliferation stress, and it blocks the P53 pathway.
So all of this is blocked if Keras is hyper active. So we want to do things that are going to slow this Keras pathway, and that's where you can get back to the slides back up here.
So some things that can decrease amtore and Keras are dietary considerations, this list, everything in yellow here looking at all these little red boxes, which are your genes that are affected Keras and amtore secondarily that you can address those things.
There are some specific nutritional pieces like curcument things that you can help address those things too.
Okay, so we can talk more about these that I do want to talk more about these individual little lectures on each one of these. That's why we have things on the EMS and sugar consumption and eating too much food. I heard it enriched foods when you have cancer and such.
So I'm trying to give you the big picture of this. All right, thanks so much.